I almost confet you know I'm thick as a
mother hey what's up G crew it's your
girl big glow and this is on the
[Applause]
[Music]
Rocks Jimmy boy gave me this shortly
after I blew up he had wanted to make a
piece and so we had came together on the
concept pink was kind of girly even
though red my favorite color I wanted to
you know be girly a little bit so
whenever I wear pink I wear this but I
don't never wear this because I don't
never got on pink and I don't want it to
clash with all the colors we got the
gorilla right here on the o I got the
name glorilla from my cousin cuz at
first I was just going by big glow
because my name glow when he first said
it I'm like this sound kind of weird but
I went ahead and went with it and that's
how glor really came about I got a brush
his teeth on here they
dinging the CMG pendic came from when I
first got signed to CMG got it gave me
this jint when I first got the CMG piece
I'm from Memphis and so like to have one
of these was kind of like a go like a
trophy when you got this it just like
you made it once you got the CMG J the
biggest label in Memphis I was just so
excited I'm like a like I took so many
pictures and videos I think the person
on my label with the most jewelry is
Gotti cuz bad got a lot too but I think
got it got the most
year ywr this the only one of these
pendings on this Pap that I bought no I
bought that one
too this means young wiy and Ratchet and
that's me and all my friends cuz we
young we will and we ratchet and you
know they was making fun of me when I
had first blew up for being ratchet so
you know I was just embracing it this
was at least 20,000 but I don't remember
exactly how much it was I just bought it
cuz I wanted it I don't like spending
that much money so it was it hurting my
heart but I wanted it and I got all my
friends they got some just like this
with they smaller the whole guy a't got
YW
pends the bread gang piece I got from
bad all the boys got brown I think he
gave me the one with the pink because
I'm the loaf girls he came on my set in
DC he had popped out and performed our s
on youan and he had gave me this he said
he proud of me so shout out the bag this
is my new baby this the newest piece of
jewelry I have I got this right before I
went on my International tour and I just
wanted something like when I don't want
to be extra and we're all the big Cubans
and everything and theend say hallelujah
cuz you know that's my middle
name and I got this three tone like I
like this cuz it's three tone rose gold
gold and white my friend had picked it
up from me and when I got home it was
just on my bed I was like oh my God it's
so cute the big glow piece got it gave
me this I had performed at the amas and
I was nominated for best female hip-hop
artist after the performance and after
the awards we had an after party and he
just gave me this shout out to God man
God going to keep me icy every award
show I ever performed that I'm super
nervous this on TV and all the
celebrities just looking at me in the
crowd IID be so nervous but it was cool
though that was one of the ones I liked
and then you know cter be popped out on
this set so we had fun
together gloss gave me this this is a
best friend bracelet it say glow and
gloss and it say best friends for life
right here so some best friend bracelets
I just got all four of these at the same
time I got that one this one this one
and this one yeah he be charging me at
least 5500 for each one and this curbin
I got on two tone too like this Rose is
gold and white so I'm like I got to get
some two tone
bracelets these my favorite set on rings
to wear the big glow 5500 for each ring
and so that was a lot of money to me
like I actually went 6 months like I
ain't buy no new JY until like last
month I bought my friend one of these
for her birthday last mon and I just got
one too cuz I liked it he gave me this
one for free when I bought all these he
knew I paid a lot of money so he gave me
this gorilla for free cross is gifted to
me I am a Christian and I believe in
Jesus I just like to wear it on
[Music]
me Jimmy boy did these grills for me
shout out Jim boy why fit and jimy boy
my favorite two people to get jewelry
from I got to get them FedEd I don't
wear them right now because they kind of
big my mouth be looking real big when I
put them in and I already talk with my
mouth closed big teeth don't make it no
better I never had grills before so I
don't know if Grill supposed to
automatically feel weird I used to put
aluminum fo in my
[Music]
mouth